let's talk about drones we do a lot of
drone talking here we drone on about
drones this actually doesn't involve the
military at least not yet Facebook is
acquiring for sixty million dollars
Titan aerospace a company that makes
atmospheric satellites and basically
what they're saying is they want to have
these drones that for five years can fly
around without being charged up or given
new batteries or anything and they want
to enable all parts of the world that
don't have the internet right now to get
the Internet I believe we have some
video of the Solara 60 drone Solara 50
and 60 can be launched at night using
power from internal battery banks when
the Sun rises the solar panels covering
the craft surface store enough energy to
allow them to ascend to a position of 20
kilometers above sea level and stay
aloft continuously for five years
without ever having to land and refuel
despite its massive size Solara only
weighs 160 kilograms and can carry a
payload of 32 kilograms it can cruise at
speeds of up to 104 kilometers an hour
about 64 miles per hour
according to reports smaller versions of
Solara have already flown okay so
Facebook wants to build 11,000 of these
things and basically they'll be flying
around as I said giving Wi-Fi to all
kinds of places that don't have it right
now one of the things that I thought was
particularly interesting was the 32
kilogram payload that makes you wonder
payload sound doesn't that sound like
bomb like Wi-Fi plus bomb he's taught us
that payload payload payload always
meant bomb who knows what they can put
in there but drop up some movies and
some Wi-Fi guy has the worst speaking
voice ever I don't want him doing the
oral report all right should we believe
that
Facebook has good intentions here we
attack phase 4 everyone attacks Facebook
all the time it's very cool and hip to
attack Facebook they're saying that they
want to so there's two thirds of the
world that don't have internet access
right now and they want to just give it
to them can we say
for a moment that maybe Facebook is
trying to do good here do you think it's
oh I think I think definitely I I
definitely I think a couple things I
think one drones have become such a
scary word in some of their contacts but
I don't think develop the technology
inherently makes them evil you know like
I think if a lot of we will have drones
in the future because flying things will
be important that doesn't mean we want
the drones that go kill people right I
think in this case Facebook is doing
doing good but not selflessly I mean
it's the reason I think I trust them on
this is that their incentives as a
company financially are aligned with
everybody having the internet and
everybody having the Internet is a good
thing so you know it works out for
everybody they want more users so
everybody having the internet works out
and those people have access to
information and learning yeah do you
think it's something about Facebook that
maybe they're starting to stall here I
mean we're hearing about that that young
people are not getting on Facebook now
so that they feel like we better figure
out what's going on in Africa and get
some new sign up you think they're doing
this just to get more client that'd be
crazy business doing something for
clients although I did like your lofty
feeling of you should know but I think
that like when you first when I first
hear this I think oh god some you know
what a waste of money and then I think
that is so important for people to be
informed and connected I mean look at
these government's that cut these people
off from information and they're
isolated I mean it's really important I
think that's a great point with
everything going on here between Egypt
and now Ukraine and Venezuela everything
else that governments literally can shut
off the internet I think in Crimea right
now they're having they're not getting
any Wi-Fi I think I could if I was
incoming I would be on the phone all day
ah I have no connection connection in
about five days yeah can you imagine how
bad Time Warner Crimea is must be
terrible but really so in that in that
regard this could be a pretty great
thing if the internet just existed right
if it just existed above literally above
government yeah I mean it raises a
different set of concerns I mean I
definitely think the reason Facebook's
doing it is because they want
more clients like I think that's but
that's what I mean anything that's like
magnanimous I think that's what I mean
but I think the incentives are aligned
like their incentives have more clients
the people's incentives have internet
everybody wins
but that said I do think it raises an
interesting concern about what what
happens when a company you know what
what happens when something is not
operated in the public trust it's
operated by a corporation and you know
we know the reasons why a government
might shut down the internet why might a
company shut down you know there is a
quote there is a corporate incentive
which is money this raises issues I mean
Facebook and Google who Google does
similar things here you know providing
internet to whole towns and stuff and
they're trying to keep expanding that I
think the issue is sort of I mean both
of those companies are very for like net
neutrality for instance but it it does
make you wonder then you know if they
have the people who have an incentive a
financial incentive to how you use that
internet also control that internet like
that does raise like classic
monopolistic with net neutrality to be
instructed I don't know that it's okay I
mean if you look at metal net you know
the health care in this country as
opposed to the health care in countries
that have socialized medicine the
incentives are very different you know
you have people advertising here people
don't advertise their people people you
know they see health as a right we see
health as a for-profit business here and
and I think that it could that's danger
what you're saying is it could be a
danger because Facebook is a for-profit
right so but is there much both in the
healthcare and an Internet is there much
difference between the companies and the
government at this point we don't have
that much difference right because even
with all this NSA stuff we keep finding
out every day that the companies they
all fight they all tell us that they're
fighting it and then they're all giving
backdoor access and all this other stuff
so it's not like we have that much
difference to make a very good point
international you know espionage
questions you know if Facebook is
willing to work with the NSA I know
they've been fighting it and
I'm not sure if they have have they been
caught yet giving back to access
practice you know you log on to Facebook
and then they track all your search
history or your web history outside of
Facebook so they're doing plenty of
stuff so it does it but it does raise
questions about you know kind of the
security of other nations the secure you
know like I don't know if giving an
American company total access to all of
their the same as the NSA issue it's
like you know we need to protect
ourselves and make sure that we know
what evil people are planning so we need
to have this broad surveillance but then
that compromises everybody's rights you
know so if we need to know what porn
you're all watching at all times I'm
pretty sure that's the final thought on
that